vielleicht ist es nur eine ansichtssache
ob es bielefeld wirklich gibt mehr als
300.000 menschen behaupten dort zu
wohnen
damit läge sie auf rang 18 der größten
städte deutschlands
doch deutschland zweifelt auch in berlin
wird gerätselt
bielefeld die stadt die es nicht gibt
statt die man halt keiner kann sie
aufweisen was ist da gibt's sexueller
vielfalt ist na ja nix 0 nada bielefeld
eigentlich gar nichts
die bielefeld verschwörung sie besagt
die stadt bielefeld existiert gar nicht
hinweisschilder ortsangaben
autokennzeichen alles von geheimdiensten
oder von außerirdischen gefälscht um die
existenz der stadt nur vorzutäuschen
vor 20 jahren fing alles an mit einem
party gag unter studenten heute schlägt
sogar die internetsuchmaschine vor
bielefeld gibt es nicht
doch was es gibt viele bücher
eines davon hat thomas walden
geschrieben
bielefeld ist glaube ich in der
außenwahrnehmung eine stadt die relativ
ja relativ nicht vorhanden ist
tatsächlich wo man also sagen würde
na ja also es ist nicht sonderlich
auffällig es gibt auch kaum gründe auf
den ersten blick zügig das mittelfeld um
die wichtige stadt wäre thomas walden
hat auch das drehbuch zum kinofilm die
bielefeld verschwörung verfasst darin
kämpfen vier bielefelder gegen geheime
mächten und sichern schließlich die
existenz ihrer stadt
gedreht wurde auch auf der sparrenburg
die mittelalterliche burg gilt als das
wahrzeichen der stadt
verhüllt wird sie aber eher
geheimnisvoll auch oliver geiger ist
darauf schon mehrfach angesprochen
worden
der journalist lebt in berlin wurde aber
in bielefeld geboren
das ist einfach so eine weiße fläche so
eine projektionsfläche auf die man so
alles drauf projizieren konnte was man
wollte und damit dann eben auch diese
bielefeld verschwörung ja keiner kennt
die stadt man kann über die stadt alles
erzählen und die leute glauben zu einem
und lachen sich tot
bielefeld als zielscheibe für hohn und
spott
das war auch mit dem gebäude der
universität nicht anders denn für viele
ist es keine uni sondern in wahrheit das
raumschiff der außerirdischen
und die scheinen unbehelligt durch die
straßen zu ziehen oder sind es doch nur
die bielefelder die in diesem jahr den
acht hundertsten geburtstag ihrer stadt
feiern an diesem tag mit einem karneval
der kulturen
viele bettes multikulti wälder wiesen
eine mischung zwischen stadt und land
dies optimal hier gut zur wege haben wir
mit der stadtbahn und wie es sich für
eine metropole gehört ist die stadtbahn
sogar eine u-bahn auch wenn nur sieben
der mehr als 60 haltestellen unter die
erde verlegt worden sind
zur großstadt wurde bielefeld 1973 als
die umliegenden dörfer kurzerhand
eingemeindet worden sind früher hat ein
eben tatsächlich gestört dass es jetzt
nicht münchen oder hamburg war er und
alle haben immer so irgendwie sich
erzählt wie geil das da ist in diesen
großen städten
und dann war eben da dieser impuls das
immer so kompensieren zu wollen und in
dem man halt eben dann irgendwie in
besonders tolle bars geht die so ein
bisschen auf großstadt machen und dann
mit besuchern auch mal so mal eben noch
mal an den tollen leuchtreklamen
vorbeifährt so weil es da so ein
bisschen aussieht wie ein piccadilly
circus
die patrizia gebäude am alten markt
zeugen davon dass bielefeld früher eine
bedeutende kaufmannsstadt war
oberbürgermeister pit clausen hat sich
dafür eingesetzt den spruch der
bielefeld verschwörung für das jubiläum
zu nutzen
bielefeld das gibt's organisch seien ein
super opener für ein gespräch weil es
mir die möglichkeit gibt dann auch zu
beschreiben wie schön wie großartig
unsere stadt das was hier los ist und
natürlich ein bisschen die werbetrommel
für die stadt zu hören
und insofern wenn es diesen europa nicht
gäbe ich glaube da müssten wir ihn
erfinden und so frei an die bielefelder
das ganze jahr den acht hundertsten
geburtstag der stadt nur beim anblick
des verhüllten wahrzeichens drängt sich
vielleicht noch der verdacht auf
bielefeld das gibt's doch gar nicht